it's the big moment we've been waiting
for the second Republican primary debate
just hours away it all starts at 9:00
Eastern and you can catch it on Fox News
and fox business but it's no ordinary
debate our very own Dana Perino is co-
modering along with Stuart vanney and
Ilia Calderon getting Dana ready for
this day is a lot harder than it seems
but we had no choice but to send Harold
Ford Jr out to California to help her
out hey Dan I'm here to help how are you
good morning oh all right uh oh yeah can
you just get my stuff out of the TR AB
that'd be the most help that you could
provide Harold thank you absolutely and
also just don't wrinkle anything yeah
sorry I'm sorry sorry everybody get out
the way we're coming Dana the moderators
here go I'm sorry somebody please get
the door please Dana's
here can someone open the door the
moderator's coming Dana come right on in
Dana come on the moderator's here can
you tell us where to go please thank you
come on thank you thank
you wait carold what what is all this
stuff where are
myf head shot and his I'll find them
I'll find them I'll find them I'll find
them I'll find find I'll find them
Harold I'll find him I'll be right
back and I got the
notes and I got you also uh Jesse sent
these these uh face masks one of no no
so so I was thinking I know you're busy
I was thinking I had a question I think
you should really think about on
inflation I've been thinking about it
how you can
frame um well you know crime is going to
be big on people no actually if you
wanted to be helpful Harold what I could
really use as a tea um and it has to be
specific okay so it needs to be 108° F
and I need a little bit of honey but you
have to put the honey in first but not a
lot of honey just a little bit of honey
you know you got to get it just right
and then you have to steep it for 3
minutes you got to make it like the
British make it because you know that's
that's my my way so if you could just
get that Stir It 15 times but
counterclockwise cuz that makes a
difference perfect I'll be great thanks
that' be the way you could be the most
helpful I'll be right back W see she
likes
this 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 Oh Lordy okay we get this thing one
here I think I got this right I can
follow the instruction so on
inflation did you you start it clockwise
didn't you you could tell see it's it's
it's no okay
sorry Harold can you can you just guys
guys Dana needs silence I'll handang
this I thought I told you guys Dana
needs
silence Harold it's you don't eat too
hot in here it's too hot let me get
something let me get something
here I got it
[Music]
Harold that's for Pence and and now it's
too cold gosh I don't know what to do
I'm I'm trying D I'm trying it's
freezing in here thank you thank you
take the FL water
back Dana Dana I've got an amazing scoop
for you Dana has no time she's no she's
preparing she has no time no time no
time wow okay okay so you know what's
been bothering me a little bit is
um well the plane is going to be in my
shot and I just we just get it out of
here something I'm uh I'll get right on
that let me get get right on that hey
tires yo think you can help me move this
plane yeah I can move
it I think I'm probably start on that
wheel right there that Wheels y very
funny okay I think I think I speak for
every body here at the table when we
heard that Harold and Dana were doing a
comedy sketch we had very low
expectations you guys hit it out of the
park great that was really good great
very good was so fun Dana did no I think
Harold really leaned into it both of you
guys that was very very funny and Harold
I thought you stirred it
counterclockwise he did that is the flaw
in the package I I caught it well if
anything ever happens to Johnny I know
where to look Harold Harold need to know
if we can hire you out to do this kind
of thing you're really good at it my my
second boss is now Dana my other's down
uh down in Chelsea her name's Emily so
we'll see if she she loans me out you
follow Direction very well Greg I think
you could use those two for exclamation
yeah I think Harold would make a great
villain don't you think that he's got a
very Bond villain look and Dana I never
knew but you know what I guess you have
a new best friend now Dana a good for
you huh oh Greg's jealous no he used you
he used you to get a free trip to
California he probably has an early tea
time with
Brett I think you guys have a future in
acting you know your comic timing was
right on and just that dead pan Dana and
that you know just dismiss I mean we see
you like that here all the
time you know but I don't think a lot of
other people you know really knew that
about you so um it wasn't easy being
mean I have to say um although it was
interesting our the driver of our of the
in the SUV at the beginning we we we did
the loop twice and he said it's okay I
worked on The Bachelor I did this all
the
time let me ask did the acting coach
just tell you to pretend you're
married now look I didn't mean to drop
the suitcase I actually dropped it twice
uh that's why it looks so natural so
organic and you just went with it which
was really great I just love that detail
about the driver working on The Bachelor
so he's really used to people coming in
there with their sues but you guys
weren't weren't crying in the back seat
that must have thrown them off a little
bit I am I am I laughing so hard I
thought that was fantastic it was great
I have a question what is what was Tyrus
doing out
there I don't know he just showed up and
he was you know he just was like I can
lift this thing and get it out of here
it is the iconic uh plane obviously this
is the Air Force One Pavilion which is
amazing uh and debate prep has been a
lot but it was so fun to lighten it up
for a little bit and certainly we miss
you guys but we feel like we can feel
your spirit we got we still got a sense
of humor oh yeah did Harold end up
actually helping you with the debate did
you take the inflation question no
comment I I think it's fair to say there
will be some sort of economy question
tonight yes all right well that was I
tell you this Dan Dana we you talked
about the outset um Jesse how we're
proud of her she is ready and uh you
look at this place that if you just
being here you in you're infused with a
sense of purpose and seriousness and uh
we got the best here so congrats and
that said luck ton I feel like we have
an excellent plan I just don't know how
the plan's going to fall apart so wait
for that well you seem loose and we have
one more special video message for you
Dana all right here it is hi Mom it's
Percy I just want to say good luck and I
miss you I know you're going to do just
great and don't worry I already have one
TV on fnc and the other on fbn hey tell
those candidates to be nice to you
otherwise I'll bite them like Commander
I kid I kid anyway break a leg tell
Stuart I hello and good luck P.S don't
bring me back any of those vegan treats
in California oh no problem absolutely
we will only bring you that was
beautiful thank you I I've not cried
this entire time but I just might I
think we almost saw here well you look
great Harold thank you so much for
keeping her loose knock him dead tonight
thank you thanks guys
congratulations great night and keep
that fly swatter handy okay exactly just
in case he needs it hi everyone I'm
Brian killme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now